I think one of the best things you can
do is also show your failures and your
struggles and how to deal with them not
just I won and try to hide it from them
because it's easy to think wow mom had
it all figured out like how did she do
it
she figured it out and she had this
successful bit meanwhile like you're
panicking and crying and like self-doubt
and so then they feel they don't measure
up and they feel inferior questions okay
so I think yeah yeah and partly I'm
doing what I'm doing in life right now
because I want to pave the way for them
I want them to see the steps that I'm
taking to make this a reality in my life
following a dream and they are watching
me obviously another role model for them
but I want to teach them how to follow
their dreams and how to make it happen
just have a dream start to follow it
don't fall off yeah I think it's too big
of a dream yeah give up yeah so I want
to ask you yeah it was your son what are
the let's say top five things you ever
want to teach him so that he could yeah
pursue history so yeah yeah yeah I hear
it one of the things we do is every time
I tuck him into bed drop him off for
school leave him for whatever reason
it's always gonna be karma clothes can
do and he says anything we do high five
so why say carmichael's can do and he
says anything and then high five
and I want him feeling like you can do
anything I think that's the single
biggest thing that my parents instilled
with me is the trusting in your wings
not the branch you can do anything
believe in yourself believe comes from
them so I think that's some kind of
ritual but they may not even understand
yet but it's like I can do anything I
can do anything I can do anything
you may not always feel they can do
anything but they'll come back to
remember I can do anything whether it's
a you know sign off
you know [ __ ] like sixteen-year-old
daughter in the bed but like any of a
phone call
well yeah put like and the message
written like and then but like involve
them in it right whatever like we heal
together or like and and and the family
day like karma girls can do anything I'm
with I'm with you on this right so yeah
okay I like that yeah yeah yeah some
kind of ritual that embraces what you
know you're looking for a lot of this is
just like what my parents are giving me
to you that I think I had the greatest
parents at one time and I'm just trying
to pay it but I can do the same thing
forward I think him so a couple ideas I
think in terms of being an entrepreneur
I think one of the best things you can
do is also show your failures and your
struggles and how you deal with them not
just I won and try to hide it from them
because it's easy to think wow mom had
it all figured out like how did she do
it she figured it out and she had the
successful bit and meanwhile like you're
panicking and crying and like
self-doubt and so then they feel they
don't measure up and they feel inferior
so letting them see the suffering
letting them see the some of the pain
and some of the hurt but then I'm
instead of instead of crying in the
bedroom I crying on the couch and it to
come and console you and then and then
getting up tomorrow and be like I'm
gonna go times my business cause I think
we shelter our kids too much and it's a
really painful thing to do for your kids
to like see you crying but I had to go I
remember like when I realized wow my
dad's not perfect wasn't good and I felt
inferior trying to like measure up to
some of the things so I think letting
them see you fail or struggle or doubt
yourself is a good thing
in that moment I felt
yeah so like seeing my dad cry seeing my
mom my mom was the more ambitious one so
see my mom fail and and that my mom was
the I always saw her success and then
she tried a public campaign and bit and
lost and that hurt her and so being like
emotionally just wasted from that but
then seeing her get back up and go after
it yes that's the actual MS oh she's not
perfect oh she fails it's okay if I fail
the most important part is getting up
and doing it again even more important
than you become a successful
entrepreneur is the drive to become a
successful entrepreneur is it dealing
with the negativity right dealing with
the any comments you get dealing with
being embarrassed in front of camera all
of that stuff and having the courage to
show them even though it hurts them in
the short term but ultimately I think
helps them long-term so it gave you the
freedom to fail yeah or to cry right I
said don't cry a lot but I'll cry
through happiness like great moments I
don't cry through sadness a lot I don't
get satellite
but I I cry during Seabiscuit you know I
cried during like great happy moments
right so having permission to do that I
think always encouraging was for let's
go encouraging encouraging them to take
another step encouraging him to do more
so the bullying example I gave where
okay you're dealing with a bully
here's how to deal with a bully the
boulders are looking for someone to pick
on
but if you see other kids being bullied
then you have to go help and again
doesn't mean you have to get in the way
and fight the bully but even if you're
just consoling the kid who got beat up
or stole lunch money I mean fun or
whatever and go sit next to them or hug
them and be with them that's a gift
right so like it's not just how you
handle it in your grade you go help the
younger kids too right so yeah and like
teaching them teaching them or like
responsibility service so every time
we're faced with a situation like that
it's it's here's how you fix it for
yourself and help others in some way as
well five I would say is we embrace
weird so if somebody calls you weird
that's awesome we celebrate it whatever
his weird ideas are like we'll do it
together even if I have no interest in
it so he wants to draw I suck at drawing
but we'll sit there and we'll draw
Voldemort from Harry Potter them
comparing them dive into his world
playing fortnight against each other
League of Legends or every three months
he wants to redecorate his room with
picked these little stickers that you
can kind of peel off the wall so like it
was Pokemon I don't like cooking mine
okay next is gonna be whatever and was
he into now he just changed it maze
runners maze runners - yeah he's in the
maze venice's so like we're looking for
maze runner stickers and you can put up
on the wall and then just trying to
transform his room
things that don't have to cost a lot of
money you know stickers on the wall go
to Amazon couple bucks you know put a
put his blanket down over the side and
we pretend it's a waterfall or you're
like move his bunk bed for his little
hidden area at the back and just little
silly things but that it's easy to as an
adult think is weird or that's stupid or
just embracing that and trying to join
him where he's at the thing that I fight
against and I think my parents did a
fantastic job is is making not making me
into them
my parents had totally different
ambitions in all three of I'm two
sisters older younger and we're all
doing different things and they always
supported us so when I was in the
baseball cards they drove me everywhere
to do sometimes hours out of town on
every weekend to to trade baseball cards
with people were in their 40s I'm to go
shoot over ten cents on something they
didn't really care about baseball at
baseball cards they didn't want me to be
like them so Hayden doesn't have to be a
youtuber you might be an artist and
that's awesome like as long as he's
happy that's great and not making him
feel like he has to do what I do
yeah and celebrating it celebrating what
makes them different weird innocent hmm
brahim - I thought you weren't on the
childhood on the wine I looked at you
and I think only child's old account
Lebanese in the joke
well I'd like to ask you some questions
yeah I want to be a father someday okay
and you being a father and I really like
to know I know it's a common question to
ask like what values do you want to
instill in your son yeah but what values
have your son instilled in you like what
have you learned from your Sonic even
the cat anecdote I think the biggest
thing is is around embracing play
embracing weird embracing it's funny how
little kids care about judgment when
they're young and they just go off and
do and how that paralyzes adults and how
that's taught me a lot so I think it was
an example my son always wears different
colored socks always he hates matching
socks you have a Batman sock and then
the green sock okay great instead of
forcing him to say hey you have to wear
matching socks where a lot of people
would like to try to force like why we
suck in the creativity out of the kids
like maybe we should be more creative so
then I'm folding my socks later that
weekend and I had a white sock extra and
a black sock extra and there were extra
like I don't know the other sock got
eaten in the washing machine somewhere
like okay well I don't know actually I'm
gonna throw him away I thought and then
my son comes to mind so I have some
pairs of socks where they're extra so I
just put them together but my my thought
that night was I should I'm gonna do it
and then I had to come in and I was
teaching the class here at EDX level six
and my first thought was
to teach class okay have a black sock in
one way and then because that was my
thought then I had to do it and not just
do it I had to embrace it so get to the
front of the class and say I pull up my
pants and like they're my socks and like
hey guys here's why I'm doing this and
make it a lesson for everybody so that
was a just an innocent he wasn't
thinking about he wasn't making a stand
for Batman socks and green socks
it just was doing it but those kind of
innocent
lessons that you can learn I love
applying to my life so that's the first
one that came to mind raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that people passion not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
it's something surreal
this interview was done as a part of my
Toronto workshop if you want more
details on the next one to sign up check
out the link right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there